well guys congratulations the two of you
are joining us in the third and final
round of this competition in this final
round we're setting you back to your
home forges for four days to build an
iconic weapon from history you're gonna
be building this
voicemails this is the naga sword
the naga sword traces its origins back
to 16th century india featuring a broad
square chiseled tip this weapon was
great at inflicting powerful deadly
chops in combat
this rare version of the dao sword was
reserved for the highest level tribal
authorities due to the scarcity of iron
in the area while few naga swords still
exist it can be seen on display in the
halls of the british museum in london
good luck we'll see you in four days
let's get it
[Music]
my name's chris smith i'm 41 years old
from bergen kentucky i'm a refractory
brick mason and a part-time placement i
thoroughly enjoy making knives it's a
lot like a rabbit hole there's new
materials coming out all the time new
tools and i just enjoy the challenge
feeling pretty good got all the
parameters met
it's time to heat treat this thing
let's hope this goes well
there was no crazy fireballs or broken
blades or anything like that the quench
went great
yeah it's hard
i am stoked this thing is going to look
awesome i got it ground ready for
etching it's going to look good
the blade etched amazing
it's time to start thinking about the
handle on how i'm going to make it i
feel like i have plenty of time
doing some research online about this
naga sword the majority that i saw had
red goat hair off the pommel of them
just as a decoration so i ordered road
hair off the internet i think it's
perfect
[Music]
i'm joseph jojo salyers i'm 19 years old
from rutherfordton north carolina
i am a full-time bladesmith with my dad
billy stylinger who just so happens to
be a fortune-fired champion billy you
are the forge of fire champion good job
brother and so here i am hoping i can
show the old man up it's coming along
pretty well
we got a solid bill of damascus
time to get my blade in the oil
with damascus you have a bunch of little
welds any of those wells could possibly
pop open i'm hoping everything comes out
all good all right
hot metal
[Music]
my sword's quenched it's pretty straight
all in all my blades mostly done most of
the work i have to do is aesthetics and
sharpening
that is what you'd like to see my dad
was kind enough to give me something to
test my blade on i personally challenge
worthy of your skills
finally a worthy opponent
yeah
i'll go on the wall we shall stuff it my
sword's comfy sharp it's done now it's
time to go see what the judges can do
with it
late smith's welcome to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i'm going to take
your weapons and put some lethal blows
or chops on this big carcass jojo are
you ready for this let's make some pork
chops you got it
all right jojo pork chops you wanted
pork chops you got
most of the weight is right here in the
handle so that really lends itself to a
nice balanced weapon your swords edge
over here chops deeply especially on one
swing on the leg and overall
it will kill awesome
all right chris your turns are you ready
yes sir all right let's do this
that's on top
all right chris the first thing i
noticed about this is just
how sharp your edge is ground and that
lends itself for very deep cuts and i
like to throw back to the 90s troll hair
right there
but overall sir your naga sword it will
kill thank you sir
all right gentlemen welcome to the
strength test the how to chop
now those houdas would be riding on top
of an elephant this test is not about
what your naga swords do to the how did
but what that out it does to your blades
and jojo you are up first you ready i
suppose so
[Music]
all right so jojo
uh there's
there's no damage it's a kind of an axe
grind but on a chopper it works fine it
held up beautifully in strength tests
well done thank you
chris you ready to play with the howda
yes sir all right
[Music]
[Music]
chris i'm going to start back here on
your handle um i like this it's got a
fairly traditional look to it
as far as your blade goes we have a
little bit of an issue
your edge
has
deflected
over to one side
but it's still sharp
other than that i think you did a good
job hold on
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
sharpness test the jackfruit and rope
slice
jojo first you ready for this absolutely
all right let's do this
all right jojo your edge cut nicely on
these jackfruits and the rope overall
it'll cut thank you
all right chris your turns are you ready
yes sir all right let's do this
[Music]
all right chris
so in cutting the jackfruit this section
went here met the jackfruits so that
includes this area that took some damage
you can feel a little bit of a drag but
it did not affect it was able to cut
through the jackfruit and the rope
overall sir your weapon field will cut
thank you
the blaze miss both your blades tested
well but only one of you can go home
with a fortune fire champion title and a
check for ten thousand dollars our
judges have discussed your blades and
they made a final decision today's
fortune fire champion is
jojo congratulations
chris
there's no doubting you are an extremely
talented smith but unfortunately your
time this competition has ended i'm
gonna have to ask you to please step off
the fourth floor all right thank you all
for having me all right thank you chris
a beautiful piece
thanks mate
i think it all came down to the heat
treatment of my blade i'm not sure what
went wrong but something obviously did
jojo congratulations that means you are
the newest fortune fire champion not
only that you are the very first father
and son champion that's ever come
through fortune fire man congratulations
i cannot wait to get home and tell dad
this is going to be super cool and he's
going to be just as excited as i am is
this a blade you'll build again
i think i'll make an extra one i need
something to show off at the house
this is so awesome i never thought i'd
be here and man it's just a blessing
jojo's the fortune fire champion let's
go up top
yeah
you